hello citizens of the reject nation greg
and john i'm i think that's who you are
john of house humphrey we are going to
watch
the comic-con trailer that we are
obviously very late to watching house of
the dragon we haven't seen
any of the trailers for how the dragon
is it'll be fresh but we did you know
cover the last couple seasons of game of
thrones right here on the channel so if
you guys want to watch those reactions
you can have already visited game of
thrones since last watching it but i am
very curious mainly because matt smith
is in this series and i i am hearing
that a lot of people are being very
receptive to everything they're seeing
and so we were like maybe we should
cover it and i'm like well if we're
planning on covering it why don't we at
least check out a trailer first and see
how we respond to the trailer so with
that in mind leave a like that wouldn't
take too much of your time so please
just go out of your way to move those
opposable thumbs and boom let's swing
action people
the dream
was clearer than a memory
and i heard the sound of a thundering
hooves
splintering shields and ringing swords
and i placed my hair up on the iron
throne
i consider the matter urgent that of
your succession
reciprocity is the most dangerous seat
in the realm
and our line is vulnerable too easily
ended
who else would have a claim
the firstborn child wow
that's horrible has ever sat the iron
front
the king has an heir damon targaryen
no queen has set the iron throne between
my brother and my daughter
[Music]
knives will come out
[Music]
you are the king
your first duty is to pick a new wife
nice
conflict
do you think the realm will ever accept
me as that queen
the lords of the realm bent the knee
a woman would not inherit the iron
throne
because that is the order of things
for
[Music]
your now has dragons
there are power men should never have
tried for cliff
whoa
more dragon action
like smaug
[Music]
she will block my way
our hearts remain as one
our hearts will never won
[Music]
[Applause]
you never imagined yourself
on the iron throne
where he sacrificed
holy [ __ ] that looks great wow
that looks really good yeah that was a
good trailer it was a great trailer it's
a
great i didn't think i'd be all right
i'm not gonna lie to you guys i did not
think i'd be excited for this show
that's the reason i've been avoiding it
and haven't really been like on yeah
yeah there's some good will to build
back after the end of game of thrones i
loved game of thrones and i still feel
like you know even with the final season
there was so much to still appreciate
about what they did however after it was
done i was like okay i'm i'm i'm i'm
ready to say bye
yeah even though i still think it's one
of the best despite its last season i
still think it's one of the best shows
ever made but then to come back to here
like this looks pretty awesome it does
look good it looks great yeah one a it
looks really really tangible and that's
the thing is like game of thrones like
upped the ante in terms of just how far
we are going to go to get these crazy
locations and these incredible just
that moment where you're like staring
through like racks of candles and
everything like you really feel like you
are in a whole other time and place and
then to go back this is based on source
material and for me that's been my
biggest thing is like what we've learned
from game of thrones is that it's a bit
of a slippery slope when you're
off-roading past the source material but
this does have a book to draw from that
gets me excited for the whole thing
because it looks great and now i'm
confident in what they have based it off
of and i love the look of the cast too
like well i mean i don't remember
everyone's name here but it seems like a
really funny thing
i heard targaryen
at one point
you know it's pretty obvious that you
got a pretty simple plot like i like
that the not the plot is simple i'm sure
there's a lot of complexities and
politics and dealing with legacy all
these things involved with you know the
world of house of the dragon but the
plot is so focused on the fight for the
iron throne and mainly focusing on the
two targaryens the brother of the king
and the daughter of the king and
watching as that comes in the conflict
and i like that conflict because they
are related they are blood and they are
fighting for the spot and it has two
completely different meanings for each
one of them you know and then i like how
that is a central focus plot so it was
easy to latch on to where you know like
that is a aspect to game of thrones uh
that is a definitely an a main
ingredient to the show but it didn't
start off as this is the central focus
of the fight for the iron throne yeah
right away and i like that they're
they're grounding it in that and you're
gonna explore the history and i think
this will even help serve the daenerys
storyline down the road because there's
so much talk in this trailer you know
with the targaryens they're going to be
a woman in there
rather see the city burn you know yeah
it's never going to happen yeah it looks
like they could definitely do some some
rhyming you know it's like poetry uh
they could do some rhyming
yeah definitely as a mechas dude yeah
sorry they could do some of that and
they could also like there's so much
made out of you know the legacy of the
targaryens even in what we saw in game
of thrones and you know the history of
dragons and all that so this does feel
like a very natural place to go that
yeah we'll have you know in impact not
impact but it will be informed by what
we've seen in game of thrones and it
will you know sort of tie in in what
feels like a very natural way to that
yeah yeah i was impressed i was
impressed it looks a little more
fantastical just because of the fact
that you're dealing with dragons much
more prevalent like the dragons didn't
even come in to play until like a few
seasons into game of thrones that was a
big part of game of thrones was the
rebirth of the dragon again and here
it still actually feels much more war
heavy
and a little bit more
it's like all these things i'm saying
i'm like no game of thrones did do that
but there is like you said the word
tangible and so it does feel a little
bit more real world yet has more of the
fantasy of the dragons yeah so it is
kind of interesting it it does feel more
like not exactly scuzzy but a little bit
more gritty and you know yeah you're in
an earlier time where it's like you know
you're already that's more of a medieval
it's already yeah a medieval sort of
dirty world that game of thrones
occupies so this being even earlier than
that has to be that much grimier and
that much more primitive in certain ways
at least yeah yeah like a harsh world to
live in
so we'll see we'll see i hope it
delivers i hope it lands and um yeah
what do you guys think are you excited
for the show should we cover it comes
out in a few weeks regardless now i'm at
a point where i'm like well i'm
definitely gonna watch it again even if
we don't react to it i'm definitely
gonna watch it
so yeah subscribe leave a like and hey
let's answer the page
ricardo of house martinez
there are no latinos in the game of
thrones universe i feel like you should
be the first latino knight to write in
they're like what was pedro pascal
pedro pascal was a martell
and they were from
you know there are hispanics in the game
of thrones universe i just uh you know
there are no not enough not enough man
especially in this part of the universe
where it's like everyone's blondes your
blonde hair like
stuff like we need you to come bring
some flavor to the iron throat chile
yeah
turn the iron throne into an iron
skillet you know throw some chili powder
on there you know make up some carne
asada or something this is getting
dangerously close to being a racist
child that's like your last chat
that's right man that's all we do here
is just dance on the phone
but uh hey buddy love you hope you're
doing well thanks for sticking with us
and hey
if you're a game of thrones fan let us
know and then uh maybe we'll shout you
out when the show's actually on
rock on rock on
[Music]
you